[Música]
Esta es la respuesta de los libaneses
con gasolina ramas de árboles lo que han
encontrado estamos frente a la casa del
presidente de la sesión de bancos del
Líbano selim esfera y como pueden ver
los debaneses han vuelto a decir basta y
lo único que quieren es recuperar su
dinero aunque tenga que ser a la fuerza
Ajá nuestros gobernantes se han llevado
su dinero y lo han puesto en cuentas
extranjeras mientras que a nosotros a la
gente corriente nos impiden poder
acceder a nuestros ahorros no podemos
vivir así quieren acabar con la gente
ahogándonos lentamente
hoy hemos venido en representación de
todo el pueblo libanés Somos la voz de
la gente eso bastardos que nos gobiernan
nos retienen ilegalmente nuestro dinero
nos ha quitado todo lo que hemos
trabajado en toda una vida estas
acciones son solo las primeras de muchas
que vendrán
mi marido es militar Y yo estoy aquí
defendiendo y apoyando a la gente desde
que empezó la revolución porque ya no
podemos más no podemos comer ya no
podemos ir ni al médico cuando tienes un
accidente y te rompes el brazo
la furia de los libaneses ha vuelto a
explotar en las calles y es que la
moneda local ha caído en un mínimo
histórico a 80.000 libras libanesas por
un dólar lo que ha vuelto otra vez a
sacar a los depositantes y a los
manifestantes a las puertas de los
bancos a exigir que les devuelvan su
dinero después de que lleve tres años
encerrados en los bancos debido a la
crisis financiera la gente está harta y
como pueden ver hoy han quemado
neumáticos gigantes de banco en la calle
vadaro pero no son los únicos disturbios
que están abiertos sino que siguen
habiendo disturbios en otros bancos en
la ciudad de beirut y en otras ciudades
del Líbano porque la gente ha dicho
basta